in an extraordinary move the United
States is pursuing full diplomatic
relations with Cuba but this won't mean
the end to the economic embargo which
only Congress can fully remove it's a
comprehensive set of economic sanctions
on Cuba that has existed since roughly
1962 it has been an absolute disaster
for both the United States and Cuba
here's seven reasons why the embargo
means that number one American diplomats
in Havana admit that the embargo was a
failure the goal of the embargo was to
put pressure on the Cuban government
economic pressure that was supposed to
create popular anger and resistance to
the government and eventually
overthrowing but according to a 2009
cable for me the u.s. s top diplomat
Havana at the time that has failed to
happen two sanctions have failed to ruin
Cuba's economy Cuba has seen a fair
amount of economic growth since the
sanctions were created indicating that
there wasn't nearly enough pressure to
send the economy into a full pale spin
and thus foment rebellion number three
the embargo has probably killed the
Cubans the 1992 Cuba democracy Act
restricted the flow of medical guns into
Cuba from the United States this
resulted in a precipitous decline in
access to medical supplies inside Cuba
according to a 2010 review by two
Stanford researchers they believed that
the lack of access to this medicine was
responsible for several disease
outbreaks in the country including an
increase in tuberculosis fatalities for
the embargo has not significantly
reduced jiva's human rights abuses Cuba
has a terrible human rights record among
other things it's one of the worst
countries and freedom in the press in
the Western Hemisphere and it throws
dissidents and bloggers into jail merely
for criticizing the regime
however there's zero evidence that the
sanctions regime has done anything to
make those abuses better 5 almost the
entire world opposes the United States
for 23 years the United Nations has
voted to condemn the Amer
policy towards Cuba the last vote in
2014 saw 188 out of 193 UN member states
opposing it in the General Assembly six
Cuba's not a state sponsor of terrorism
anymore some of the sanctions on Cuba
come from the u.s. designated Cuba a
state sponsor of terrorism because of
its support for the Basque terrorist
group etta and the Colombian group FARC
now according to the State Department's
from most recent review there's no
evidence that Cuba is providing material
military support to these groups
moreover he was cooperating with Spain
on the transfer of Ed to prisoners and
it has been sponsoring a peace
conference in Havana for the FARC and
the Colombian government one that
appears to have resulted in a unilateral
ceasefire declaration by the FARC seven
a majority of Americans support
normalizing diplomatic relations with
Cuba and majority support relaxing major
parts of the embargo including
restrictions on US companies doing
business in Cuba now Cuban Americans
also appear to oppose the embargo if the
people who have the most reasons to hate
the Castro government have come around
to thinking the embargo isn't worth the
costs it's time to reconsider the policy